[Musique]
Jo lon bonjour bonjour vous êtes
conseiller municipal de de voisin mais
vous êtes surtout le le président de Sky
goolf
2018 et c'est pour ça qu'on se trouve
aujourd'hui au golf national on va en
parler en fait vous êtes l'homme qui
essaie de faire aimer au aux habitants
de Saint-Quentin des sports qui ne
connaissent pas forcément ça a commencé
par la voix là je crois ah oui ça fait
déjà n années maintenant pendant 10 ans
avec la comité d'agglomération nous
avions créé une association qui
s'appelait les 7 de Saint-Quentin et qui
portait donc le nom des des des villes
de de sa-qutin en Yveline et qui avait
armé un bateau pour faire le tour de
France à la Voile Tour de France à la
voile avec un skipper champion olympique
était tiieré péponnais et pendant 10 ans
on
a on a défendu les couleurs de de
Saint-Quentin et on a gagné le Tour de
France à la Voile d'ailleurs en amateur
on a gagné en professionnel et on
l'avait fait aussi quand après on a le
bateau a été baptisé Saint-Quentin
université Versailles Saint-Quentin
parce que Versailles s impliqué avec
nous dans le projet et là on a a couru
en grandes écoles malheureusement on
avait en face de nous des grandes écoles
comme l'école navale et cetera et là on
n pas réussi à gagner on en fa ça fait
beaucoup parler de sa qutin évidemment
alors c'est très amusant parce que
effectivement quand on était euh dans
les Pors le long des côes Françaises et
qu'on nous remettait des coupes parce
qu'on gagnait quand même pas mal de
régates les spontanément les habitants
de Saint-Quentin venaient à nous en nous
disant en se reconnaissant dans le
projet en étant heureux de savoir que
les couleurs de Saint-Quentin étaient
porté le long des côes Françaises et euh
ça a permis effectivement de donner une
image dynamique et sportive à à 50h en
iveline parmi bien d'autres activités
comme vous le savez alors le le golf ça
demande pas de la d'avoir de la mer on
va parler de justement de skygolf 2018
alors 2018 faut rappeler ça sera la
rider Cup qui aura lieu ici même au golf
national et et c'est quoi l'ambition de
Sky de de de skygolf c'est de faire
connaître ce sport aux habitants de de
saanta oui alors parce que c'est évident
que la rider Cup est très connue des des
golfeurs des spécialistes des sportifs
et cetera
monde entier mais et dans le monde
entier c'est faut savoir que c'est la
trème manifestation sportive la plus
regardée au monde c'est je crois que
c'est des des centaines de une centaine
de millions de de téléspectateurs quand
il a la Raider Cup en revanche c'est
assez peu connu de du du du public en
général enfin de de ceux qui suivent pas
le golf en particulier et d'avoir la
Raider Cup en France en 2018 c'est
exceptionnel c'est comme si on la
première fois qu'on avait la Coupe du
monde de football ou c'est un événement
majeur qu international et on a la
chance d'avoir cet équipement magnifique
on a sans doute avec l'Albatros qui est
derrière nous le le théâtre golfique ça
on l'appelle le unique au monde
c'est-à-dire que on peut ici on va
accueillir pendant le rider Cup près de
80000 personnes par jour et tout le
public pourra suivre les compétitions de
quelques points qu'on soit au fond parce
que c'est surélevé et c'est un à ma
connaissance c'est le seul golf de de ce
type au monde et il conu pour ça il été
conçu pour ça voilà donc c'est c'est
vraiment ça va être un événement
d'importance or cet événement qui encore
assez loin en 2018 oui on se dit 2018 on
a le temps ben oui mais déjà la
l'organisation de la rider demande qu'on
que les pays qui organisent soient prêt
en 2 ans avant c'est en 2016 donc 2016
ça va arriver assez vite plus vite
surtout que ici le terrain va être
refait remodeler redrainer que le le
l'hôtel va être agrandi qu'il y aura un
deuxième hôtel à construire et cetera
enfin c'est il y a des infrastructures
importante et c'est dès maintenant qu'
veut s'en occuper et on veut donc l'idée
c'est que et on pourrait s'en occuper
sur la population voilà c'est oui mais
enfin ce serait fort dommage quand même
qu'e manifestation de cette importance
là soit découverte au dernier moment par
la population de Saint-Quentin et qu'il
se qu'il viennent peut-être ou qu'
viennent pas mais qui se disent mais de
quoi s'agit-il donc on va D mant
apporter l'information qui va bien à la
population
essayer de faire toucher un club à un
club de golf à tout ceux qui le voudront
c'estàd que l'idée c'est queouir
siniciier quoi le ctinois qui qui veut
savoir quoi ça ressemble il est la
possibilité gracieusement évidemment ave
en venant à lui non pas en le faisant
venir parce que on sait très bien que
quand on fait venir quand on fait les
porte ouvertte au golf ben il y a des
gens gens qui vienent des gens qui pas
mais il y a des gens qui n'osent pas qui
se disent c'est un sport d'élite c'est
c'est pas pour pour nous et cetera alors
que VO il y a une image qu'il faut
combattre parce que c'est V qu'on dit
oulite riche oui
vieux il serait venu là en début de
semaine il y avait une compétition on a
joué sous la pluie je peux vous dire que
la moyenne d'âge était plus près des 35
ou des 30
ans les champions aujourd'hui c'est des
vrais jeunes des vrais sportifs des
athlètes donc l'idée c'est de de donner
un possibilité à tous les Tinois de
venir voir de près à quoi ressemble une
compétition de golf déjà les initiés
c'est-à-dire leur expliquer comment ça
fonctionne parce queil faut faut
connaître que quand on regarde une une
compétitionation né à la télévision
c'est pas forcément très très facile de
de comprendre comment ça marche parce
que on passe d'une image à l'autre d'un
d'un joueur à l'autre et tout donc il
faut aller vers le vers le public et lui
expliquer comment ça fonctionne et la
tirer vers vers vers le golf aujourd'hui
il y a 1500 adhérents euh sur
Saint-Quentin dans féà non à la
Fédération de golf il a 1500 adhérents
vous êtes une centaine d'assation
multiplié par 2 ce serait bien d'avoir
3000 joueurs de golf sur 5qu1 et puis à
la pour répondre à votre question dans
l'association nous sommes une centaine
au mois de novembre quand on a lancé
l'association il y a une une compétition
nocturne golf nocturne ce qui se fait
pas beaucoup avec des
balles phosphorescantes c'est amusant et
à cette occasion là on a récupéré si je
puis dire ou du moins on a on a vu une
centaine de personnes adhérer
spontanément à notre association ah
c'est pas mal quand Mme ouais c'est
quand dit vous dites il faut venir vers
eux il y a il y a notamment une manière
ce que ce qu'on appelle le street golf
c'est ça voilà alors
euh la le weekend avant l'OP de France
c'està-dire fin juin pendant 3 jours le
vendredi soir et le samedi et le
dimanche euh il va y avoir du golf dans
les rues de de Saint-Quentin autour du
centre commercial de
Saint-Quentin avec non parce que ça va
être ça on va taper des balles avec des
balles spéciales qui qui volent pas
comme des vraies balles évidemment et on
va taper audessus du plan d'eau qui est
au centre commercial et possibilité à
ceux qui voudront venir essayer de taper
dans une balle de golf voilà essay
quelle
est la réaction justement de la la
population vous commencez à la la la
voir un peu est-ce qu'on on parle un peu
de cette TRC parce que c'est encore
quelque chose pour de de lointain et de
alors quand quand on en parle et qu'on
explique de quoi il s'agit évidemment
les gens sont assez sidérés quand on
leur dit que il y aura 80000 personnes
par jour qu'il va falloir mettre 5000
mobile hommes ici sur les plateaux pour
accueillir la population que dès
maintenant il y a des il y a des sites
qui se sont créés pour que les les gens
puissent mettre à disposition proposer
des des logements pour les les visiteurs
étrangers qui viendront il faut savoir
que aujourd'hui tous les hôtels de la
région sont déjà réservé par les
japonais c'est il y ajà déjà donc ça ça
va vraiment poser un problème
d'organisation et d'accueil de la
population donc quand on leur dit ça ça
les étonne beaucoup et il il commencent
à mesurer que ça va être une une
manifestation son importance et ça veut
dire que quoi il va falloir agrandir
l'offre par exemple de logement ou de
non enfin ça je pense pas que ça ça va
être pour autant l'occasion de
construire des logements même si
SaintQuentin a besoin de logement et
Dieu sait s'il va y en avoir dans lesn à
versaill à Paris oui oui non mais bon
puura les moyens de transport qui iront
bien je pense qu'il faudra s'ganiser
mais pour répondre à votre question sur
comment aller vers eux effectivement le
street golf ça va être ça c'estàd qu'on
donnera la possibilité au à la
population cquanttinoise ou aux autres
ce qui passeront dans la région de venir
voir de près à quoi ressemble la
pratique du golf il on en parla un tout
petit peu tout à l'heure mais il y a un
obstacle en effet à à surmonter c'est
peut-être l'image que que peut avoir ce
sport dans dans la population où on a
l'impression en effet que c'est réservé
à quelquesuns quoi alors que vous le
dites hein dans l'association c'est pas
plus cher qu'un notre sport ça peut être
accessible alors euh faut faut savoir
que ce la pratique du golf est quelque
choseextrêmement répandu dans les pays
anglosxans oui euh c'est un atout
d'ailleurs pour la ville pour
Saint-Quentin que d'accueillir cette
manifestation parce que les entreprises
anglo-saxones qui veulent s'installer en
région parisienne il y a dans les cadres
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de de cadres
dans les sociétés anglo-saxones
qui qui sont qui sont demandeuses de de
de pratique et et de terrain donc ça
c'est déjà un plus pour pour 50 en
Eveline
et on
a conscience que on
doit ouvrir à la population de manière
large et pour ça on a commencé par les
école c'està-dire que depuis le mois
dernier il y a initiation au golf pour
les élèves de des écoles primaire ça
c'est déjà fait sur guillancour ça va se
faire sur Manille etameau ça va se faire
sur montinis ça va se faire sur voisin
boitonneux et aujourdh tous les gamins
auront tous
unont taper dans dans une balle de golf
et les premiers qui ont initié euh ça
c'est les c'est gu en court et il y a eu
déjà 200 enfants qui ont eu l'occasion
de pratiquer un peu de golf et ça très
très bien marché c'est un succès
incroyable donc euh il y a aucune raison
pour que derrière les enfants n'aient
pas envie d'aller plus loin et ils ont
là aussi la possibilité avec le la le
golf de la Fédération ici sur euh sur
Saint-Quentin de d'adhérer et de
d'apprendre à jouer au golf moi j'ai des
j'ai mes trois fils ont appris à jouer
au golf ici et ils ont passé leur brev
sportif et il faut savoir qu'un jeune
qui passe les brevet sportifs peut aller
jouer il peut y jouer jusqu'à ses 18 ans
gratuitement gratuitement et et la
formation pour des jeunes étaai à des
prix extrêmement modiques c'estàdire que
c'est ça coûte pas plus cher d'apprendre
à jouer au golf quand d'aller jouer au
foot ou au basket donc c'est voilà c'est
il faut faut essayer de créer cette
ulation parce que ce sport ne demande
qu'à se développer en France et on a
besoin d'élite on a besoin de de joueurs
nationaux puisque la dernière Raider Cup
Europe contre les États-Unis
malheureusement il y avait pas un seul
Français non il y a pas de français
alors ça c'est un espoir qu'on peut
avoir peut-être avec la formation
justement des jeunes c'est que d'ici
2018 il y a un talent quiclire mais bon
ça c'est autre chose ouai c'est autre
chose l'association à la skygolf 2018
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça donne
dans être membre et enfin qu'est-ce
qu'on demande aux membres alors on
demande déjà de de nous rejoindre pour
porter les les couleurs de de
l'association et de la de 5
enine auprès de de la population en
général mais ça va leur apporter aussi
de de d'être très proche de cette
organisation de pouvoir en tant que
bénévoles tout ça les associations c'est
toujours du bénévolat évidemment c'est
pouvoir apporter de leur temps pour
faire découvrir le golf par exemple aux
défi natures qui va avoir lieu le
weekend prochain on va avoir un un stand
avec un accueil pour la population et
bien ce sont des bénévoles de
l'association qui vont qui vont animer
ce cette cette prestation enfin qui vont
assurer cette prestation là donc c'est
c'est d'être au contact un peu si je
voulais dire dans un peu dans l'œil du
cyclone quoi voilà si si en 2018 c'est
un peu le goobbywin aussi entre entre
voilà entre le golf la rider Cup et puis
la population exa sachant qu'entreetemps
il y aura les Open de France et là aussi
pour les membres de l'association
l'occasion pour eux d'être au plus
proche peut-être des organisateurs de
l'Open de de pouvoir participer en tant
que bénévole dans l'organisation de
l'Open enfin on peut imaginer beaucoup
de choses quoi en plus alors faut
peut-être te préciser il y a il y a ce
ce golf qui est évidemment magnifique
qui sera celui de la rider Cup mais il y
a aussi à la base de loisirs de
Saint-Quentin un un superbe golf enfin
avec de 18 trous je crois il y a de 18
ou et un U trou et un U trous donc là
aussi où il y a des initiations qui sont
qui est un golf qui qui est ouvert au
public et bien c'est c'est un des des
golfs de la région parisienne qui est
tout à fait abordable alors c'est vrai
que les weekends c'est peut-être un peu
chargé c'est pas toujours facile mais en
tout cas en semaine ou le soir par les
les beau jours qui ne tarderont pas
j'espère c'est un sport qui quand vous
savez quand vous achetez un matériel de
golf il vous dure des années hein c'est
pas si vous jouez au tennis vous changez
des raquettes souvent vous jouez au foot
vous changez de chaussures enfin bon
c'est
c'est la comparaison peut se faire et
pas forcément des avantages du golf par
rapport à d'autres sports merci
infiniment et puis on retrouve
évidemment sur le site de de
l'association he skygolf oui Sky goolf
2018 on a un blog donc G
oup
Manise just pour voil rendre plus
populaire merciiniment merci
[Musique]
deue